the first thing I want you to see is
what this is is like a typical set of
different vehicles right and the
different kinds of running costs
associated with so obviously this is all
fictional but instead you know it's not
outside the realm of possibility okay
now this is not annual stuff have a look
carefully at what's provided to you how
far are these cars driving in EP a--
15,000 kilometers in here now be that
you guys have not drivers you probably
have no sense for whether that's a
realistic number or not is that what is
that little what do you think it's
probably expected so I thought maybe I
should give you guys some numbers right
um I went in the cold out to my car
right can you see it can you see it this
is just a yeah thank you so yeah so yes
it's all ah but it runs just fine okay
now you can see there's the oh that
that's about 30 that's OD which stands
for is ever made Oh Dominic which is
tracking how many kilometers are driven
the wife of the car now I can tell you
right now odometer let me write it for
you cuz you should we should know
okay when you're ready you're 11 by the
way there are a lot of warning lights
because I hadn't turned my car all the
way on so it always screams were
learning before you turn all your Donna
says 28,000 out of it close now I'm have
this car for three and a half years in
that space of time I'm very lucky I live
only a couple of suburbs over i'm
driving to work bag perform every day
not like i have to commute in your city
okay so think with me think with me
28,000 you got a calculator there let's
just go 28,000 three to five years how
much am i driving or media not very far
let's make that important it's okay now
if then we can all agree that if you're
doing like parsing poetry book or I'm
epping the charitable and that's all
you're doing every day then that's going
to be a pretty small enough they'll be
most people who drive a lot further than
that okay and there will be people who
their job is like a regional and they're
driving you know maybe a hundred
thousand kilometers in the space of a
couple years very quickly okay so
they're on the other end 15,000
kilometers not a bad number okay so
we're going to go with that we're going
to do a small number of these questions
together by interpreting this table okay
so walk with me the first question we're
going to have a look at is question 2
okay so we're going to try and read this
interpret it and see what's going on
which vehicle has the best fuel
consumption and the worst fuel
consumption okay so you've got the
question you're here now let's come back
to this table okay so what we're doing
is we are giving we are given model
information as if all these cars drove
the same distance so which number should
we be looking at yeah you want to look
at this some this row along here right
this is the amount that each car is
expending on fuel now you'll notice
there's a cell that's blank over there
what's that about question
okay so there are some missing things
here now by the way can I just point out
you're like oh this is a bit speed
artificial isn't it that I have to feel
these missing things in this table
actually not that artificial because
this number down here right that'll be
the number that you know most easily
because it's how much you're feeling it
on your bank account and your credit
card statement it'll tell you what all
of your expenses are even if you're not
keeping track of what they are okay so
therefore this is not as unrealistic as
it sounds in this row there's just this
one over here that we want to fill in
how do i do it how I find that unknown
okay so all sorry all of these numbers
here they should add up to 11,000 633 so
this number that's left should be the
difference between 11,000 633 and all of
the other expenses so can someone
calculate it for me 2005 just frozen
2340 yeah okay good so now that we have
all of those prices there which one is
the let's do the best first which is the
most efficient car yeah it's the one
that's I'm spending the least so I'm
going to put it let's put it in green
because that's a good thing here we go
hooray for the corolla it's a small car
that's why it's more efficient because
it just has to like less weight around
okay so let's actually just write that
in there so this guy here most efficient
okay um I now want the other end of the
spectrum so which is the least efficient
of all of these cars that's right so hun
Saleh would be disappointed you can see
here the Ford Falcon here that was
pretty hot um it's the least efficient
because you're spending the most money
but you're going the same amount of
kilometers is the rest of them right so
let's mark that in or you might like to
write in your book that the ford falcon
is least efficient okay by the way I
just point out I said you're the toyota
corolla it's going to be more efficient
because it's small it's got less weight
to carry around you also should pay
attention when you guys are buying a car
so not just the size of the car like how
big is it but pay attention to the size
of the engine does
anyone know how they measure engine
sizes does anyone know yeah say yeah
they'll measure in capacity capacity as
in like 1.5 liters for instance which is
uh which is the capacity of the engine
of my old toyota corolla it's a really
really small number as a coincidental
coincidence when I was growing up my
family drove a Ford Falcon and its
engine was 3.9 leaders in capacity
because it's a number that's stuck on
the back of the car you walk past it
every day so just have a look at those
have a look at those two numbers does it
surprise you that that Ford Falcon is
using so much petrol because the engine
is bigger it's burning lots of petrol
all the time yeah so is this how you
measure like what 3.9 leaders on what
Petroff that it can burn at any given
time so that's why you get more power
out of that and why my poor turtle crawl
I couldn't really climb hills okay so so
there we go most and least efficient
let's have a look what else isn't asking
us here we go and that was question to
the next one I want to look at is five
be so I'm skipping a few here because
you can read this and you can go through
all of them I'd really what percentage
of the tow rating costs are fuel costs
for I can is it really good these
percentages this is what we're looking
at in the starter questions right so
we're looking for let's do the toyota
rav4 because we just looked at the
corolla okay so i have a look which
column and we look out for the round
four that's this one over on the end
that we filled in okay so here are other
petrol costs and here is the total costs
right so how am I going to work out the
percentage of the total cost yeah yeah
very good let's let's all write that
down 2 340 and I'm comparing it to the
entire price that's why I'm dividing by
that number and in origina into a
percentage i'm going to multiply by a
hundred percent okay i give me one
decimal point
20.1 percent that's odd that is a lot
that is a lot and petrol is expensive
right and we use our cars on what so
whereas whereas for instance if you
drive very little right then this price
is going to be a smaller percentage of
the whole thing right because other
things like insurance and registration
will be more expensive okay good so we
know how to compare numbers here let's
have a look what else is it going to ask
us I want to skip down to question 7
because this one requires some thought
what would be the fuel costs just the
fuel cost to drive a Ford Falcon from
Sydney to Melbourne a distance of a
hundred eighty five kilometers okay um I
don't know and I hope I've demonstrated
I'm really bad at guessing at numbers
like this so I'm just gonna go with that
no more 885 which column are we
interested in here which column it's the
yeah it's the fourth one along right
this guy here ok there's the fourth
Falcon so I want to go 885 kilometers
and I want to know how much that costs
how do I do that what do you reckon how
far is um how far is this cost here
representing yeah 15,000 kilometers
under mm1 we looked at when you compare
quantities that are different measuring
different these like say kilometers and
dollars what do we call those when you
can pray things that are different we
call that a rate ok so i'm going to
write two thousand nine hundred forty
seven dollars that's how much it costs
to go how much again 15,000 kilometers
right so with someone like to suggest to
me how i turn that rate into something
that will give me the answer for eight
hundred and eighty five kilometers yeah
Jess yeah very good so this is the this
is the unitary method right I want to go
one kilometer on the right hand side
what do I have to divide that by 15,000
which means of course you can't just
divide the right hand side divided four
left as well
okay can someone give me them in dollars
what that's going to be it's going to be
less than a dollar give me a few more
okay now the reason by the way I've
written down a few is because when i
multiply by 885 that's how many
kilometers I've got right if I introduce
a little bit of rounding here that
rounding is going to get taken out of
proportion because I'm doing 885 times
right do you remember one way of looking
at the area the perimeter sorry of a
polygon the more times you use a
calculations been rounded the more area
you introduce right well I'm going to
make this error 885 times bigger than it
was before so even if it's small it's
going to matter so you can see how to
put a whole bunch of decimal places
that's per kilometer and of course I
actually want 885 kilometers right so
can we multiply this number by 885 and
get an answer a hundred and seventy
eight and I'll just go to the new scent
because I don't need to I've Donald my
round E yeah now that's not bad
considering a arm what is this is this
city development did we say should
remember Sydney to Melbourne and air and
air fare is about a hundred bucks I mean
you can get a bit lower than that if you
get like a next day ticket it goes a bit
higher than that if you're in pink but
that's only one person right whereas I
can fit five people in that car might be
a bit squashy but I can do it okay